herzlich willkommen zur folge
192 des faz einspruch podcast der
wöchentlichen podcast der faz für recht
justiz und politik heute am 12 januar
2022 die erste folge im neuen jahr mein
name ist corinna budras ich bin berlin
korrespondent in der faz und an meiner
seite ist wieder piano ransmann und
frohes neues jahr auch von mir wir sind
wieder zurück aus einer kleineren
winterpause und wollen mal mit einem
großen dank staaten denn zu unserer
letzten drachen lord folge zu unserem
großen spezial kurz vor weihnachten
haben wir jede menge hörer post bekommen
über die wir uns wirklich wahnsinnig
gefreut haben waren viele anregungen
weil der schönen gedanken und auch viel
lob dabei und das wollten wir natürlich
zum anlass nehmen um zu sagen weiter so
ja bitte bitte feedback schicken und
auch konkrete vorschläge machen
vielleicht für weitere themen das freut
uns immer sehr kann man am besten direkt
an uns schicken und da einspruch podcast
faz.de und auch anderweitige kanäle
suchen also zum beispiel gibt es ja auch
die möglichkeit immer kommentare auf
unserer webseite zu hinterlassen
genau wir fangen natürlich wie immer an
mit allen neuigkeiten aus der korona
welt es gibt ein paar neue beschlüsse
die du uns vorstellst relativ das thema
im moment sind aber auch die beliebten
sogenannten corona spaziergänger da gibt
es tatsächlich rechtliche neuerungen die
wir euch mal vorstellen es könnte
schwierigkeiten damit geben diese
spaziergänge zu untersagen
naja und dann hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht sich mit dem
heiklen thema der triage
auseinandergesetzt auch diese
entscheidung wollen wir vorstellen und
nach diesem sehr langen krone blog
kümmern wir uns dann um den sehr
umstritten fdp politiker jens maier da
stehst du uns die gemengelage vor pia
jens meier möchte nämlich um das schon
mal vorweg vorwegzunehmen wieder richter
werden ja und nach all dem was er als
ich als auf die politiker geleistet hat
ist das ein ziemlich dickes ding so und
dann haben wir noch updates und hörer
post und diesmal nicht nur eins sondern
zwei gerechte urteile
[Musik]
ja also stürzen wir uns in unseren
bunten corona strauß denn da haben sich
ja kann man sagen die entwicklung
überschlagen in den letzten wochen wir
haben ja eine recht ruhige weihnacht
phase gehabt auch erwartbar ruhig weil
ja die inzidenz sich kaum bewegt haben
ganz im hinter sind eher runter gegangen
was natürlich auch mit der mit unser
test strategie zusammenhängen haben wir
jedes jahr aufs neue die problematik
dass zwischen den feiertagen dann auch
länger nicht oder weniger getestet wird
und wir ein recht diffus bild haben und
auch vor diesem hintergrund war dann
anfang der des monats anfang des jahres
kann man sagen die aufregung in der
politik recht groß es wurde viel
diskutiert auch um kritische
infrastrukturen und was omikron so für
diese kritischen infrastrukturen und
auch für die infektionsketten
bedeutet und deswegen gab es im
vergangenen freitag das nächste
bund länder treffen also da haben sich
wie der bundeskanzler scholz und die
bundesländer zusammen gesetzt also
natürlich in gestalt der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
und sind so einigen
beschlüssen gekommen wie ist denn aber
jetzt die aktuelle lage die eben auch
hintergrund war für die neuen bund
länder beschlüsse in sachen omikron hast
du dann noch mal ein paar daten und
fakten für uns gerade genau also da
haben wir es ja mit einer neuen variante
zu tun die uns seit woche auch schon
ziemlich alarmiert sie ist sehr viel
ansteckender aber die verläufe sind
wesentlich milder das ist ja immer diese
merkwürdigkeit mit der wir es zu tun
haben dass wir einerseits hier
alarmglocken schrillen und andererseits
auch entwarnung gegeben wird ja und im
grunde genommen hat der neue chor ohne
rad also diese experten das
expertengremium das die bundesregierung
in diesem zusammenhang auch berät hat
einfach davor gewarnt das ganze so ein
bisschen auf die leichte schulter zu
nehmen denn die ganze sache mag zwar
milder verlaufen die erkrankung mark
miller sein aber trotzdem rechnen viele
mit einer hohen belastung der
krankenhäuser wegen des zeitgleichen
auftretens sehr viele
infizierte also selbst wenn nur wenige
schwer erkranken sind es ja dadurch dass
es jetzt inzwischen über
80.000 neue infizierte am tag sind das
ist ja schon wirklich eine hausnummer
mit der wir bis vor kurzem noch gar
nicht rechnen konnten und da sind
natürlich dann auch im verhältnis
wesentlich höhere zahlen von auch
schweren verläufen dann in diesem
zusammenhang genau das kann sich wohl so
ein bisschen verschieben innerhalb der
krankenhäuser nach dem was die
wissenschaftler innen im moment so von
sich geben das heißt es könnte so sein
dass eben die intensivstation vielleicht
nicht mehr ganz so stark ausgelastet
sind sondern die normalstation dann
stärker ausgelastet aber am ende an der
gesamtzahl ende das dann natürlich wenig
und man rechnet eben nicht damit dass
die belastungen der krankenhäuser
zurückgeht obwohl die variante eben
weniger schweren verläufen genau das
kann man vielleicht an dieser stelle
auch noch mal deutlich machen übrigens
die krone war apple hat er immer den
wahnsinnigen vorteil dass sie einem die
statistik auch immer so wunderbar
deutlich macht auf einen blick wir haben
jetzt also eine sieben tage in stands
von 407 um momente und die
hospitalisierung rate
stagniert so ein bisschen bei etwa 3 ja
und das ist ja die untere stufe
von dem was wir bisher schon gesehen
haben aber von entwarnung kann keine
rede sein und deswegen hatte man sich
zusammengesetzt und aber guckt wie die
welche unterschiedlichen neuen
regelungen nötig sind um vor die welle
zu kommen wie sehr immer so schön heißt
obwohl ich auch verstanden haben was
wird eigentlich sein soll und da ist ja
jetzt vor allem die
quarantänevorschriften werden verkürzt
also man kann die quarantäne massiv
verkürzen da ist ja schon auf den ersten
blick ein bisschen erstaunlich wenn man
sich anschaut wie viel neue fälle es
geben wird richtig und dass es hat eben
zu tun mit dem ersten punkt die nicht
genannt hat nämlich das omikron sehr
viel ansteckender ist und wir deswegen
seit tagen diskutieren was passiert
eigentlich mit den kritischen
infrastrukturen also mit dem
gesundheitswesen allen voran natürlich
mit den pflegestationen und
krankenhäusern mit der polizei und
feuerwehr auch wasser und energie
versorger fallen darunter ja aber
übrigens auch andere partner kommen wir
vielleicht gleich noch darauf zu
sprechen ja also das war etwas was zu
jahresbeginn auch hier sehr die politik
beschäftigt hat und wo man dann das
gefühl hatte da müsste man die aktuellen
kantine regeln anpassen und dazu muss
man wissen wie es bisher waren das fand
ich nämlich ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich
überraschen man doch irgendwie das
gefühl hat man beschäftigt sich ja zwei
jahre lang jetzt doch ziemlich intensiv
mit dem thema und es gibt immer noch
dinge die sich dann so zwischendrin mal
ändern die man dann nicht
hundertprozentig mit krieg und die dann
doch zu erstaunlichen wissenslücken
führen also deswegen habe ich mich mal
ein bisschen verstärkt damit den
quarantine und isolations regeln
auseinandergesetzt und da war es gab es
ja grundsätzlich mal die annahme und
auch die vorgabe dass sowohl
kontaktperson als auch infizierte für 14
tage sich ab sondern müssen ja also
basis übrigens all dessen ist natürlich
das infektionsschutzgesetz da konkret §
28 und auch § 30 nur für die gis ganz
genau wissen wollen so und dann gab es
aber bisher verschiedene ausnahmen die
so häufig genutzt werden dass sie fast
schon wie die einem die regel vorkam
also und zwar konkret bei einigen
varianten wie die data variante die bis
vor kurzem noch alles beherrscht hat gab
es eben eine auf eine ausnahme zb für
geimpfte und genießen da konnte man sich
nach fünf tagen frei testen ja ach guck
an das wusste ich auch nicht aber im
grunde auch da wieder die absolute rege
die normale regel vorgegeben vom rk ii
und dann umgesetzt durch die
bundesländer ist eben eine quarantäne
bzw isolations zeit von 14 tagen aber
wenn die
impfungen also wenn die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse ergaben
dass die impfungen eben doch hinreichend
gut sind und eine wirksamkeit entfalten
gegenüber den jeweiligen varianten das
war bei data der fall dann konnte die
quarantäne bzw die isolation verkürzt
werden warum
unterscheide ich so zwischen quarantäne
und isolation also ehrlich gesagt hat
sich ja jetzt eingebürgert dass alles so
ein bisschen ein topf zu werfen und das
unter die quarantäne regeln zu fassen
ich finde das kann man auch wirklich
getrost er machen aber wir sind ja nun
hier auch einfach
podcast und dafür vielleicht an dieser
stelle einmal gesagt quarantine ist
eigentlich der fachbegriff der auf
kontaktperson zielt während tatsächlich
schranke dann in die isolation gehen
müssen ja ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ob
das so sinnvoll es überhaupt diese
unterscheidung zu machen aber im gesetz
sehe nun mal so vorgesehen so und
deswegen war in eben interessant das als
unicom hier rein raus
standen die gesundheitsämter eben vor
dem problem dass man dann wieder zurück
zur regel zurückkehren musste nämlich 14
tage und das hat schon im dezember für
probleme gesorgt zum beispiel in den
krankenhäusern ich hatte mit dem am 2
nicolai so was kann hier in berlin
berlin nach köln wahn gesprochen in der
vergangenen woche und er sagte also ganz
klar schon in berliner krankenhäusern
waren wir im dezember eigentlich so weit
dass durch diese ganze omikron fälle
dass viel personal viele mitarbeiter aus
krankenhäusern in
kantine hätte geschickt werden müssen
und zwar 14 tage lang aber da hat man
dann zum beispiel so genannte arbeits
quarantäne angeordnet da kommen wir
übrigens gleich noch zu aber da hat man
schon die notwendigkeit gesehen da jetzt
auch generell mal eine ausnahme zu
schaffen und nur das ist hier passiert
das sollte man vielleicht auch noch mal
deutlich machen also im laufe der
letzten anderthalb zwei jahre hat man
immer wieder die quarantäne regeln
angepasst und nur für omicron hatte man
es bisher nicht gemacht und das war aber
diesmal begleitet durch wesentlich ja
heftigere diskussionen wie wie ist denn
jetzt die alle die aktuelle regelung
genau also was ist jetzt dabei
rumgekommen
also ist soll auch hier vor allen dingen
ausnahmen für gepostete menschen geben
denn um das vielleicht auch immer
deutlich zu sagen omikron haben wir
jetzt hier haben leider den effekt dass
die erste und zweite impfung nicht die
volle wirksamkeit sagen zeigen wie sie
zb bisher bei der beta variante galt
also diese scheinen nicht ganz so
effektiv zu sein deswegen ist überhaupt
fraglich ob man nach zwei impfungen
schon in angesichts von omikron von
einer vollständigen impfung sprechen
kann oder ob man nicht ehrlicherweise
sagen müsste darüber gemacht hat ist ist
geimpft im sinn gesetzes quasi und da
das werden wir jetzt hier auch gleich
noch sehen
dann geht die reise also man muss offen
gestehen all das was wir jetzt an
regelungen und neufassung haben ziel
tatsächlich darauf sukzessive die leute
darauf vorzubereiten dass man eigentlich
nur noch mit einer booster impfung
vollständig geimpft ist so und
kontaktpersonen also nicht infiziert
sondern kontaktpersonen mit dem booster
impfungen sollen von der kantine
ausgenommen werden und zwar grund das
gilt übrigens auch für frisch geliftet
was ist damit jetzt wieder gemeint
friske impfte sind dann die bisher
vollständig kämpften aber also doppelt
geimpften bald wieder mit einem stoffen
aber nur bis zum bis zu drei monaten
also dann verliert man seine neu
geschaffenen status des frisch kämpften
kriegs sachen knall nach einer weile
oder also ja ich glaube auch ehrlich
gesagt dass das praktisch niemand mehr
versteht mittlerweile und ich bin auch
sehr gespannt wie das kontrolliert
werden wird also kommt da gucken dann
jetzt die leute in sich auch noch
genauer pass an wann die letzte impfung
war und schauen sich an ist es jetzt
mehr als drei monate her wenn es die
zweite impfung war wenn jemand die
dritte impfung hat ist es egal und so
als ich meine da wird es dann wirklich
irgendwann ein wenig absolut also die
gesundheitsämter werden jedenfalls genau
hingucken denn die sind ja dann auch
diejenigen die in quarantäne schicken
wobei man ehrlicherweise sagen muss auch
von diesem modell haben wir uns in der
praxis ein bisschen verabschiedet das
sagen also kommunalpolitiker relativ
klar die sagen also die gesundheitsämter
kommen nicht mehr wirklich hinterher er
auch mit der kontaktaufnahme von wie
gesagt von kontaktpersonen die müssten
sie dann eigentlich
bewerten und dann auch in quarantäne
schicken inzwischen geht die ansage
dahin dass man an die verantwortung des
einzelnen appelliert ja und sagt also
bitte bitte kontaktperson selbst wenn
ihr den wisch vom gesundheitsamt nicht
bekommt begebt euch in quarantäne
ja es sei denn ihr seid gepostet oder
frisch kämpft oder genießen also für
diese drei gruppen sind
inhalt hat inzwischen drei
ist die quarantäne
aufgehoben oder ausgeschlossen oder wie
man doch wenn ich jetzt aber in
quarantäne muss wann kann ich dann
wieder raus ja für alle anderen endet
isolationen quarantäne nach zehn tagen
in der regel sagt man und das frühestens
sieben tagen ist ein pcr test oder
achtung hier kommt wieder in neun neue
gruppe die mir nicht bekannt war also
pcr test oder ein zertifizierter
schnelltest ist möglich nach 7 tagen
schon auch das ist wahrscheinlich schon
wie sollen jetzt eine liste geben soweit
ich weiss ehrlich institut die die
sozusagen sie hat die schnelltests
antigen schnell test testen wollen und
dann quasi eine liste von von ich habe
mal qualifizierten tests aufstellen
wollen
strenger ist es in krankenhäusern da
geht es nur nach einem negativen pcr
test und wiederum locker ist es bei
schülerinnen und schüler und
kita-kindern die können schon nach fünf
tagen sich durch pcr test oder antigen
schnelltest aus der kantine befreien da
ist die argumentation
wegen dieser serien test strategie in
den in den schulen und kitas manchmal
auch sagen die wände getestet quasi am
laufenden band ich frage mich ob die
eigenen augen was anderes machen
ja also das zu diesem ganzen komplex es
tut mir wirklich leid ist weiß es ist
vielleicht auch nicht ganz einfach
nachzuvollziehen aber so sind nun mal
die regelung und wir dachten wir tragen
sie hier mal nach ich würde gleich der
ordnung halber sollte man noch sagen ich
glaube das haben vermutlich alle schon
mitbekommen aber man sollte sagen zweig
plus geht jetzt in der gastronomie und
so weiter aber auch da wiederum nicht
für gewusst hatte die brauchen also
keinen zusätzlichen test wenn sie in die
kneipe möchten und auch hier das meinte
ich vorhin mit dem hinweis dass die
regelung dazu darauf zielen dass man den
begriff oder den impfstatus vollständig
geimpft versucht neu zu fassen also auch
hier wieder die erkennen dass zwei
impfungen reichen eigentlich nicht und
statt zu sagen okay jetzt ändern wir den
status vollständig geimpft ist man nur
nach drei impfungen fühlt man jetzt eben
zwei gibt plus 1 wo man sagt man auch
noch einen tagesaktuellen test dazu alle
die die nur zu einfach geimpft sind und
die dreifach
geimpft sind also bewusst sind
können sich wie bisher auch problemlos
in jedes café und restaurant
setzen
so also das übrigens sorgte das kann man
vielleicht an dieser stelle auch noch
mal sagen natürlich für wahnsinnigen
aufschrei in der gastronomie die
wirklich stinksauer sind dass sie das
jetzt überprüfen müssen sie fürchten
eben auch umsatzeinbußen
das ist eben auch das was man jetzt
immer wieder sieht man also zweig im
einzelhandel hat natürlich dem
einzelhandel hat den ganzen geschäften
kurz vor weihnachten auch wahnsinnig weh
getan also insofern
es ist also für die wirtschaft wirklich
nicht leicht für die ganzen auch viele
unternehmen die hilfen werden verlängert
und so weiter aber natürlich ist dann
eben vieles davon doch wieder nur ein
darlehen und so weiter ich glaube das
hilft dann wirklich nur begrenzt vor
allem den kleineren unternehmen vor
allem gesamten gastronomie bereich ich
kann vielleicht noch einen ganz kleinen
schlenker machen über die arbeits
quarantine weil ich darüber auch
gestolpert bin in der vergangenen woche
und das einfach total kurios fand weil
das etwas ist ein institut was
tatsächlich in dieser pandemie auch
schon häufiger genutzt wurde von den
zuständigen gesundheitsämtern auch
durchaus verhängt wurde in einigen
bereichen und das fand ich deswegen so
kurios fall ist quasi die normale
isolation die normale quarantine
modifiziert also man da mussten
natürlich zu hause bleiben man darf
nicht einkaufen gehen man darf nicht
öffentlichen verkehr nutzen man darf
schon gar nicht freunde treffen aber man
darf arbeiten ja ist ja auch irgendwie
eine unschöne situation so ist es
fraglich das schlimmste ist gut mehr
sagen kann natürlich unfassbar viel spaß
machen dass medien der stelle natürlich
nochmal methoden aber auf der anderen
seite ist das natürlich gibt es schon so
ein bisschen
gibt es wohl wenn man sich das eben
vorstellt dass in das hat in kritischen
infrastrukturen bisher stattgefunden und
betraf übrigens konnten sowohl
kontaktpersonen also leute die im
kontakt zu infizierten hatten und sich
eigentlich aus sicherheitsgründen mal
hätten absondern dann müssen das betraf
diese gruppe und aber auch infizierte
die keine symptome haben was ja insofern
auch logisch ist weil in diesem moment
wohl symptome hast bisher eben nicht nur
eine gefahr für andere sondern bist ja
auch selber betroffen und dann schlicht
und ergreifend krank dann geht das was
immer bei krankheit eine rolle spielt
nämlich dass du mal schön zu hause
bleibt und nicht arbeitest ja aber so
richtig verstehe ist trotzdem noch nicht
denn wenn die leute zur arbeit gehen
also der die wenigsten menschen gehen ja
zur arbeit und treffen dort keine
anderen menschen ach so wie funktioniert
das dann mit arbeits quarantäne also ist
passiert um ein beispiel zu nennen das
hat vor allen dingen in einer in der
fleischverarbeitenden industrie
stattgefunden also gerade zu anfang der
panini erinnern wir uns gab es ja
teilweise fälle wo hunderte von
mitarbeitern in einem schlachtbetrieb
betroffen waren ja in einer großen
fabrik gleichzeitig die haben sich alle
gegenseitig angesteckt die den
symptomlos waren die sind tatsächlich
zur arbeit gegangen teilweise haben die
ja dann auch in diesen packender gewohnt
sind ja häufig noch prekär beschäftigte
beziehungsweise leute die dann auch in
so wohnungen untergebracht werden wir
hatten erinnern uns noch vor anderthalb
jahren gab es ja wirklich auch durchaus
große skandale wo denn auch deutlich
wurde wie die untergebracht wurden also
mehrbettzimmern und man sich auch gar
nicht wundern konnte dass die sich
eigentlich alle angesteckt haben und was
bei dieser aufregung so ein bisschen
untergegangen ist ist die tatsache dass
man dann versucht hat wirklich ein sehr
sehr
pragmatischen weg zu gehen nämlich
normalerweise hätte dieser betrieb und
das hat uns viele also mehrere betriebe
betroffen letztlich hätte man diese
betriebe schlicht dichtmachen müssen ja
aber tatsächlich hat man sich dann
entschieden die leute in gruppen
zusammenzufassen von infizierten
zusammenzufassen wie gesagt symptomlos
infizierten die dann einfach weiter
gearbeitet haben und zwar dann natürlich
hat man darauf geachtet dass die die
hygiene regeln einhalten mit maske und
so weiter und so fort aber da war zum
beispiel die argumentation gras bei
dieser fleischverarbeitenden industrie
hätte ich zum beispiel auch nicht als
kritische infrastruktur gefasst ja wäre
mir so nicht in den sinn gekommen aber
da war die argumentation
die
schweinezüchter also die landwirte die
mit diesen tieren
arbeiten sind darauf angewiesen diese
tiere auch tatsächlich an den
schlachthof
abzugeben also so zynisch und wies das
klingt aber so ist die lieferkette
verarbeitungskette in diesem bereich und
da sind spezielle fristen einzuhalten
und in dem moment wo eine
eine station quasi stockt und nicht ihre
arbeit leistet gerät alles durcheinander
da war tatsächlich auch das tier wollen
argument wo gesagt wurde
sonst also ich weiß nicht wie man sich
das konkret vorstellen muss aber sonst
stapeln sich die tiere bei dem landwirt
ums mal ziemlich salopp zu formulieren
ja und der kann eben nicht mehr dafür
sorgen dass die tiere den ausreichende
einerseits betreuung oder dann auch
ausreichenden platz in den stellen ja
und dann hat man eben mit diesem
argument gab es die anordnung dass die
mitarbeiter weiter arbeiten müssen gibt
es denn diese arbeit quarantäne jetzt
immer noch also wird das in kritischen
infrastrukturen immer noch praktiziert
ja also tatsächlich ist es eben so dass
er sah was kann den hatte ich eben auch
schon mal erwähnt das ist der amtsarzt
von neukölln mit dem ich vergangene
woche gesprochen habe er hat ziemlich
deutlich gemacht dass diese kontakt also
diese arbeit kantine für kontaktpersonen
auch im krankenhausbereich
angeordnet wurde im vergangenen dezember
weil oder damit hat man zumindest
begonnen weil eben ansonsten keine ärzte
kein pflegepersonal
übrig geblieben wäre ja um sich um die
mitarbeiter zu kümmern und wie gesagt da
handelt es sich nicht um infizierte aber
um kontaktpersonen die nach den
geltenden regeln
ja also in 14 tagen in quarantäne
gegangen oder hätten gehen müssen und
das haben sie dann nicht getan also die
mussten zur arbeit gehen um den
natürlich auch da wieder unter großen
hygienischen vorkehrungen also das nicht
so dass man dann alles machen kann und
das dann auf einmal alles alles gilt als
hätte sozusagen diese diesen kontakt zu
der korona infizierten person niemals
gegeben also und wie gesagt im
krankenhaus sind ja sowieso die
hygienevorschriften
groß aber das gibt es eben weiterhin
und bei infizierten wird das natürlich
im sehr viel strengeren und geringerem
ausmaß angeordnet aber ich fand das
ganze zu creos das ist ja einfach mal
zum besten geben wollte auch vor dem
hintergrund dass die arbeitgeber also
sehr bundes die bundesvereinigung der
arbeitgeberverbände
auch vor dem bund länder treffen
eindeutig darauf hingewiesen hat und
darauf dafür plädiert hat dass das
weiterhin möglich sein muss und sogar
noch vielleicht eine einheitliche
gehandhabt werden könnte damit sich dass
die unternehmen darauf einstellen können
weil wir haben es ja hier in der tat
interessanterweise bei omikron wenn das
so stimmt wie es im moment aussieht
nämlich dass zu wesentlich eher milden
verläufen führt ja viel häufiger diese
situation dass leute sich ab sondern
müssen die eigentlich überhaupt gar
keine symptome aufweisen und dann auch
die roma waren apps blinken ja jetzt
schon überall ruhe also wird die hälfte
meines freundeskreises ist schon
irgendwie musste sich schon ab sondern
daher ist es natürlich irgendwie mit
blick auf die kritischen infrastrukturen
durchaus sinnvoll es war aber jetzt noch
nichts in den beschlüssen drin oder also
ich habe zumindest nichts dazu gesehen
ich glaube das ist noch so alles im
fluss und soll wird glaube ich relativ
zeitnah noch näher geregelt werden dass
neben infrastrukturen ja man muss
ehrlicherweise also das wird ja dann
alles wieder umgesetzt was jetzt die
arbeits quarantäne angeht hat mich dass
auch nicht sonderlich gewundert dass es
in den beschlüssen nicht auftauchte weil
es einerseits natürlich ein sehr
sensibles thema ist und auf der anderen
seite ja eigentlich auch gar keiner
neuregelung bedarf also es wäre zwar
schön wenn es mal einheitlich angewendet
würde das macht jetzt im moment jedes
jede kommune so wie sie denkt ja aber
auf der anderen seite gibt es dieses
instrument ja auch nicht das heißt
tatsächlich musste ja auch der den
einzelfall genau angucken also das so
weit jetzt waren wir auch schon länglich
mit diesen beschlüssen befasst und komm
jetzt nun aber mal zu was anderen wollen
wir jetzt gott zu den
spaziergängern kommen
genau so schön es ist ja ein ein hippes
thema im moment die sogenannte korona
spaziergänger bist du dran und ich was
ihren wer
meine er mit spazieren ich bin auch
tatsächlich noch nie eingeladen ich
wohne so ein bisschen außerhalb der
stadt von daher bin ich in köln noch nie
in so eine in so eine demo reingelaufen
die ist das ja schon mal passiert ja das
war noch eine klassische querdenker die
emo damals sind die gerät man ja in
bedient die häufiger aber das ist ja
jetzt neues phänomen vielleicht für die
wie das irgendwie verpasst haben dass
ich da auch die struktur ein bisschen
gewandelt hat na also wir sind jetzt
weggekommen von den klassischen
querdenker dem muss die ja auch um
durchaus für einen gebucht sorgte also
angemeldet und dann mehrere tausend
wieder eine schlange bilden und ihre
transparente hochhalten das wie gesagt
hat man ja quasi im ganzen sommer immer
mal wieder gesehen
und jetzt haben wir die sogenannten
spaziergänge sind quasi nadelstiche oder
wie muss man sich das genau vorstellen
ja das sind quasi nadelstiche dass also
das wort spaziergang ist natürlich ein
ein fieses fremming um es mal so
deutlich zu sagen und soll suggerieren
aber das ist natürlich harmlos ist ich
glaube es gibt kaum ein harmloses wort
mit einer harmloseren konnotation als
das wort spaziergang
sonntagnachmittag muckelig familie und
so auf der anderen seite soll es aber
suggerieren dass dass es sich um
spontane zusammenkünfte handeln würde
und das ist natürlich
versammlungsrechtliche relevant
eigentlich muss ich sagen fanden wir das
alles gar nicht so relevant weil wir
dachten das ist irgendwie rechtlich
alles relativ klar aber es gibt jetzt
tatsächlich ein neues rechtliches
problem was sogar größer werden könnte
nochmal nach schätzungen auf das hat uns
eine entscheidung des ovg rheinland
pfalz anfang der woche gestoßen und
deswegen haben wir uns entschlossen euch
das problem doch nochmal mitzubringen
also das thema beschäftigt ja gerade
sehr viele kommunen weil er
deutschlandweit corona skeptiker und
skeptikerin auf die straße gehen um
gegen korona maßnahmen zu demonstrieren
ist hinlänglich bekannt dass sich da
irgendwie sehr viele rechte darunter
mischen dass es aber auch ein serbischer
sehr stark ich sage mal esoterisches
klientel ist also gehen auch ganz
normale familienväter und mütter mit
also sehr gemischte klientel es kommt
trotzdem häufig zu ausschreitungen
vor allem aber ist natürlich das
hauptproblem dass die ja gegen korona
maßnahmen demonstrieren und man deshalb
mit einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit davon
ausgehen kann dass sie sich an corona
maßnahmen die als auflagen während der
versammlung gemacht wurden von den
behörden auch nicht halten werden so
deshalb versuchen viele kommunen solche
spaziergänge als ein paar gemein
verfügung zu untersagen eben mit dem
hinweis darauf dass man davon ausgehen
muss dass die infektionsschutz vorgaben
nicht eingehalten werden das problem ist
man deutlich zu sagen dass es ein neues
problem also wir hatten wie gesagt
bisher eine demo von den querdenkern die
haben die angemeldet und dann gab es
natürlich auch da
wieder situationen in denen die
zuständige behörde die verboten hat und
dann hat man sich vor gericht getroffen
und hier das besondere ist eben dass sie
ja gar nicht anmelden gar nicht bescheid
werden sondern sich über telegramm oder
wo auch immer
verabreden und auf einmal so schwupp
kommt da irgendwie so eine gruppe von 20
30 50 leuten vielleicht auch mehr also
wachsen ja dann auch immer an aus der
quasi auch nichts die polizei ist nicht
darauf vorbereitet die kann wieder die
versammelten schützen noch dafür sorgen
dass alle irgendwelche auflagen auf
einen halten die ja gar nicht verhängt
werden konnten im vorher geraune also
das ist natürlich bestenfalls ein
bauernschlaue trick wenn man sachen halt
wir nutzen quasi nur eine lücke im
versammlungsrecht sage ich jetzt mal und
technisch aus dann
ausschließlich spontane versammlungen
dürfen ohne anmeldung stattfinden das
ist also der hintergedanke ist
eigentlich wenn jetzt spontan irgendwas
passiert was weiß ich es gibt ein
anschlag irgendwo da so dass sich dann
menschen spontan versammelt das ist
erlaubt es ist in deutschland auch
insgesamt erlaubt sich zu versammeln um
das nochmal klar darzustellen das
versammlungsrecht ist ein grundrecht und
zwar ein sehr sehr wichtiges grundrecht
und man darf sich immer versammelt so
dass es erst mal so zu sagen das was was
über allem steht
allerdings muss man eine versammlung in
aller regel anmelden und wenn die
versammlung angemeldet ist dann kann sie
natürlich auch mit auflagen versehen
werden dann also was jetzt her derzeit
sehr häufig gemacht wird es eben dass
gesagt wird was ich maximal 100 leute
dürfen sich versammeln mit abständen
häufig wird auch gesagt nur ortsfeste
versammlungen damit eben es keine
aufzüge gibt wo man natürlich keine
abstände einhalten kann oder
gewährleisten kann und das möchten
natürlich diese sogenannten
spaziergänger alles umgehen das heißt
sie sagen hoch wir haben uns doch hier
spontan versammelt ist quatsch das wird
ja genau ob sie wo kommen denn für die
vielen menschen er ist natürlich alles
bullshit auf deutsch gesagt die haben
sich natürlich vorab verabredet vor
allem über soziale medien vor allem über
telegram das ist auch so ein bisschen
lustig dass die sich quasi aus dem
versammlungsrecht raus schummeln wollen
denn eigentlich schützt ja das
versammlungsrecht das grundrecht der
versammlungsfreiheit so dass sie sich
immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig
verhalten damit aber egal ist
wahrscheinlich konsequent weil sie
fühlen sich ja vom staat drangsaliert
und dann versucht man diese sukzessive
der kreativen ansatz gut auf der anderen
seite ist es aber ihr merkt schon dass
ist jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen
grundlagen des versammlungsrechts ist es
natürlich so dass eine versammlung auch
verboten werden kann zwar nur in
ausnahmefällen denn wie gesagt es gibt
grundsätzlich das recht sich frei und
ungehindert unter freiem himmel zu
versammeln aber werden verstöße gegen
die öffentliche sicherheit und ordnung
zu erwarten sind dann dürfen die
behörden selbstverständlich sagen die
versammlung verbieten wir man kann
versammlungen auflösen wenn eben es dort
dann nachträglich quasi verstöße gegen
die öffentliche ordnung gibt
und man kann natürlich auflösen jetzt
gab es relativ viel ausschreitungen von
teilnehmenden an solchen versammlungen
es gab eben relativ viel ärger mit den
behörden und du hast schon gesagt jetzt
wird versucht das per allgemeinverfügung
zu verbieten weil man natürlich sich
nicht von diesen sparten angeblichen
spazieren gehenden
sie sich da an der nase herumführen
lassen möchte als behörde und sich von
diesem fremming nicht täuschen lassen
möchte so und da muss an dieser stelle
glaube ich noch mal deutlich sagen was
eine allgemeinverfügung eigentlich ist
eine allgemeinverfügung besagt zum
beispiel dass man sich an platz xyz vom
so geschehen jetzt in der entscheidung
des ovg rheinland pfalz die wir euch
gleich vorstellen ich glaube von ende
dezember bis anfang januar nicht
versammeln darf so dass finden natürlich
die leute wie dich so richtig cool und
klagen dagegen so und zwar
deutschlandweit und dadurch ist jetzt
ein problem auf geblockt dass
tatsächlich ein neues problem ist und
was über diese grundlegende kollision
versammlungsfreiheit auf der einen seite
und infektionsschutz auf der anderen
seite weit hinausgeht und zwar geht es
mal wieder um die letzte neuerung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
wir erinnern uns ist das ende der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite
da hatte der bundestag also die jetzt
heutige ampelkoalition die möglichkeiten
der länder eingeschränkt corona
maßnahmen zu verhängen nun gab es aber
immer wieder mehr kuddelmuddel die
korona zahlen stiegen wieder an die
länder wollten mehr maßnahmen für
behalten und so kam dann sukzessive
immer mehr immer wieder dazu an
maßnahmen was möglich wurde insgesamt
haben wir da jetzt ein relativ
misslungenes gesetz mit 1000 hin und her
verweisen und ausnahmen und gegen
ausnahmen und fristverlängerungen und so
weiter und jetzt ist es so dass
bundesländer auf landesebene eine
epidemische lage feststellen können
weiterhin und dann viele der instrumente
die ihnen vorher zur verfügung stünden
standen immer noch anwenden darf aber es
gibt einen abschließenden katalog von
maßnahmen die auf jeden fall nicht mehr
verhängt werden dürfen der steht in 28
absatz 8 infektionsschutzgesetz für die
uranerz da draußen also egal was
passiert dessen folgende maßnahmen nicht
mehr verhängt werden doppelpunkt und da
steht unter nummer drei versammlungen
und aufzüge im sinne von artikel 8 des
grundgesetzes dürfen nicht mehr
untersagt werden
system
ag ist wie ist das gemeint
genau also das oberverwaltungsgericht in
rheinland pfalz hat sich diese frage
auch start gesagt das ist aber jetzt
ganz schön schwierige rechtsfragen
am ende haben die ein verbot von diesen
sogenannten montagsspaziergängen war das
da glaube ich bestätigt aber nur weil
sie gesagt haben im eilrechtsschutz ist
das zu komplex wir können das nicht
prüfen und mehr wird im eilrechtsschutz
ja eigentlich gar nicht geprüft ob als
dass man sagen ist das verbot jetzt
offensichtlich rechtmäßig oder
rechtswidrig und dann ging im einzelfall
da die die abwägung zu lasten dieses
bürgers aus der da gerne spazieren gehen
wollte in anführungszeichen das ist aber
gar nicht so wichtig sondern die haben
gesagt diese rechtsfolge ist zu
schwierig jetzt dass wir das jetzt
klären könnten
und sie haben gesagt es spricht einiges
dafür dass der 28 also diese
infektionsschutz sonderregelung die sagt
versammlungen dürfen nicht mehr verboten
werden eine infektionsschutz rechtliche
spezialregelung ist und dann würde die
das allgemeine versammlungsrecht sperren
das heißt die allgemeine möglichkeit
natürlich eine versammlung unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen zu verbieten
würde dann nicht mehr bestehen weil man
ein vorrang des spezial gesetzes hätte
und dass die leute doch jetzt nicht
notgedrungen dass jede demonstration
nicht verboten werden darf es dürfen
weil es im infektionsschutzgesetz
steht ja nicht demonstrationen verboten
werden die einen bezug zu krone
aufweisen oder wie muss ich das
verstehen na ja das kann man sicherlich
und unterschiedlich verstehen es kann
aber eigentlich dann nur um
versammlungen gehen die verboten werden
sollen wegen infektionsschutz maßnahmen
also dass ich es war somit führen und
womöglich auch benutzen ist
selbstverständlich natürlich weiterhin
genau es geht nur um sozusagen
demonstrationen die nicht stattfinden
dürfen wegen corona maßnahmen so weil
man sagt da wird vermutlich gegen den
vertrag zu verstoßen so aber diese
vorschrift könnte dann sperren und dann
könnten die kommunen keinerlei
möglichkeit mehr haben ein verbot
deshalb zu verhängen so jetzt sagt das
gericht natürlich selber bot in den wird
ersichtlich selbst irgendwie mulmig und
sie sagen selbst na ja wenn das so wäre
wenn wir so eine grundsätzliche
sperrwirkung hätten was heißt das denn
dann und kann es nicht ausnahme von
solchen grunzen von von diesem grundsatz
geben so und mehr haben wir nicht in der
pressemitteilung wie gesagt ein
verfahren aber muss schon sagen das ist
echt eine blöde situation denn ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher so hat die
ampelkoalition das ganz bestimmt nicht
gemeint wer ich bin wer ich anderer
meinung also ich bin mir überhaupt nicht
sicher ich weiß es auch nicht
interessanterweise ist das eine noch
über die wir damals gar nicht diskutiert
haben weil sie schlicht auch durch diese
durch diese spaziergänge die ja damals
noch gar nicht so virulent waren
überhaupt gar nicht diskutiert wurde ja
also wir haben ja aber vieles diskutiert
damals gab ja auch ein die eine oder
andere sendungen die wir mit
schwerpunkten der belegt haben aber über
das versammlungsverbot haben wir uns
nicht unterhalten so und ich könnte mir
vorstellen wenn man mal die gesamte
pandemie geschichte
sich anguckt dann gibt es ja in der tat
ein sehr heikles kapitel nämlich grad zu
anfang der pandemie als die behörden
also sehr überschießend reagiert haben
um das mal so zu formulieren und
tatsächlich ja wir über mehrere wochen
ein komplettes
versammlungsverbot hatten ja also wo
gern auch niemand gegen irgendetwas also
keine rocker demo keine keine corona dem
onyx das durfte sich niemand versammeln
und das war etwas was das
bundesverfassungsgericht in einem der
wenigen entscheidungen die sich gegen
den gegen die staatlichen maßnahmen in
sachen krone gerichtet haben das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht sehr deutlich
gesagt das geht nicht
ja das versammlungsverbot über wochen
hinweg artikel 8 war quasi aufgehoben so
und ich könnte mir vorstellen das
übrigens nicht nur der fdp auch die
grünen sich vorgestellt haben bei der
formulierung dieser norm dass wir diesen
zustand nie wieder haben wollen jetzt
kann man sagen es natürlich immer noch
was anderes ja weil das ist jetzt eine
reaktion der kommunen über eine
allgemeinverfügung auch auf etwas was
versammlungsrechtliche auch sehr heikel
ist diese spaziergänge sind ja auch er
tatsächlich eine umgehung der
möglichkeiten starts da einzugreifen
vielleicht ist es dann für diesen fall
doch nicht so gemeint aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass die ursprüngliche
intention tatsächlich eine sehr
grundsätzliche war genau also ich glaube
auch dass die ampel koalition mit
sicherheit ausschließen wollte dass es
kategorische versammlungsverbote wiegen
corona gibt also genau das was passiert
ist in den ersten wochen und monaten der
pandemie wo halt eben auch viele
kommunen völlig überreagiert haben und
obwohl das gar nicht so in den gesetzen
oder verordnungen drin stand einfach
gesagt haben hier versammelt sich
überhaupt niemand punkte egal wo gegen
wofür und egal wo so und genau das
wollte die ampelkoalition mit sicherheit
ausschließen das glaube ich auch ganz
sicher wollte die ampel koalition aber
nicht erreichen dass man unter keinen
umständen mehr anti corona maßnahmen
demos von corona leugnern verbieten kann
die sich an keine corona regel halten
also das sind ja zwei völlig
unterschiedliche dinge nur das steht da
halt nicht also ich glaube dass die
intention schon relativ klar ist und
dass die intention bestimmt nicht wahr
jegliches versammlungsverbot wegen
infektionsschutz auszuschließen aber das
steht dann ich muss man ganz klar ich
also da hätte ich jetzt immer insofern
dagegen als das ist ja nicht heißt dass
man gar nichts gegen diese demonstration
machen kann du musst die halt erstmal
laufen lassen es kann ja auch auflagen
in der situation erteilt werden das ist
dann weniger formalistisch als man das
im vorfeld machen kann da werden die
natürlich schriftlich festgehalten
sodass der
versammlungsleiter und organisator weiß
woran er sich zu halten kann er hat
spontan situation kann natürlich auch
die polizei auflagen verhängen kann also
sagen pass mal auf
hier natürlich corona mundschutz
selbstverständlich abstand halten und so
weiter und dann natürlich auch auflösen
ja also auf einer sammlung kannst du
einen moment dann nach auflösen wenn
systematisch dagegen verstoßen wird und
du merkst dass diese auflagen in den
wind gehostet sind ja aber also dieses
instrument hast du ja immer noch und ich
könnte mir durchaus auch vorstellen dass
man im staat zumuten möchte oder das die
ampelkoalition dem start zumuten möchte
zuerst mal quasi die versammlung
zuzulassen um jedem einzelnen
sowohl den rechten da hat es natürlich
für vergebene liebesmühe aber auch den
esoterikern und in den besorgten eltern
die versammlung durchzuführen
und zu machen und sich unter beweis zu
stellen und da auch zu zeigen dass sie
eigentlich demonstrieren können weil
also man muss umgekehrt sagen also die
sind allgemeinverfügung sind natürlich
schon auch heike
versammlungsrechtliche natürlich also
jeder einzelne davon bewegt sich in
einem massiven verfassungsrechtlichen
konflikt also nicht dass wir uns hier
missverstehen auf jeden fall das ist
schwierig das macht kann man nicht
einfach so raus hauen und sagen hier
hier versammelt sich jetzt mal keiner
die nächste woche auf gar keinen fall
ich möchte das nicht verharmlosen aber
also da sind wir dann tatsächlich mal
ausnahmsweise unterschiedlicher meinung
ich bin mir schon relativ sicher dass
die ampel koalition das so sicherlich
nicht gemeint hat ist aber auch völlig
irrelevant dieses gemeint hat denn es
steht halt so drin steht und damit
genau also die sogenannten spaziergänger
werden sich jetzt darüber freuen also da
muss man schon sagen dass die
versammlungsverbote wegen
infektionsschutz nochmal derzeit
zumindest mal nicht easy going sind da
müsste man eigentlich irgendwie drüber
hüpfen und es wäre jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen lächerlich und gas sich zum von
mir zu sagen man kann ja darauf hoffen
dass der 28 infektionsschutzgesetz
relativ schnell wieder geändert wird
aber falls ich da mal jemand dran macht
wäre es echt ein guter zeitpunkt um das
klarzustellen wie das eigentlich gemeint
ist und gegebenenfalls ein
gesetzgeberisches versehen was ich halt
vermuten würde da vielleicht richtig zu
stellen ansonsten gilt das ding bis 1903
er aber gibt es denn die möglichkeit
dass ich jetzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht noch einmal
einschalten in dieser frage naja das
bundesverfassungsgericht anrufen jaja
aber im alfa fahrer also das ist ja die
wiederum das schöne bei diesen
demonstration dass das da das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch
durchaus eingreifen kann in diesem
eilverfahren
ja wenn es angerufen wird genau aber ich
wüsste nicht dass das jetzt irgendwie
gerade im gange ist oder so also dabei
weniger arbeitstage ist ja die
möglichkeit dass wir sozusagen es reicht
ja nicht wenn wir beide uns das hier
gegenseitig fragen sondern es muss her
vielleicht auch mein einer klärung
herbeigeführt werden und es könnte ja
dann auch sein dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht
jaja deiner meinung
ja zuneigt und dann das auch flexibler
handhaben auflegt ja richtig und wir
insofern für die kommunen jetzt gar kein
problem haben wenn also ich will nur
sagen ist eine interessante materie
offensichtlich eine die auch viele
gemüter bewegt und da an dieser stelle
wollte ich mal hinweisen auf ein sehr
interessantes interview was der kollege
simon strauß hier im podcast für
deutschland geführt hatte mit dem
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten michael
kretschmer der haben viel über
ostdeutsche identitäten gesprochen ist
wirklich wahnsinnig interessantes
interview aber gestolpert bin ich ein
folgender stelle viele der
demonstrationen sind auch nicht zu
rechtfertigen natürlich einen
gastronomen der geschlossenen us studios
geschlossen hat eine kosmetik hat alles
recht und kann man auch verstehen dass
sich ab tituliert und sagt ich fühle
mich hier getroffen aber die tatsache
dass die krankenhäuser überlastet sind
des menschen sterben und dass man diese
schutzmaßnahmen ergreift damit gäben
nicht sterben das ist doch ein so hohes
auch ethisch und moralisch ist gut dass
man dagegen zumindest nicht als nicht
unmittelbar betroffener jetzt
demonstrieren kann ich hätte verständnis
wenn die menschen auf die straße gehen
würde sagen wir brauchen mehr impfstoff
wir brauchen mehr medikamente dass wir
ein gründe aber aber nicht gegen
schutzmaßnahmen rhi ganz klar
menschenleben retten so und ich muss
sagen also darüber bin ich wirklich
gestolpert ich war durchaus empört denn
was der ministerpräsident der sächsische
ministerpräsident tatsächlich macht es
den leuten vorzuschreiben ging was sie
demonstrieren können also was sinnvolle
ziele sind für eine demonstration für
eine versammlung und was sie tunlichst
lassen sollten und das hat mich doch
irgendwie sehr befremdet wie ging es dir
damit ja das ist also ganz ehrlich ich
war sprachlos als ich gehört habe
und da muss man natürlich auch sagen
dass ich die die diskussion
massiv verschieben also ich glaube das
was wir jetzt wohin dargestellt haben es
halt eine rechtsfrage dass da gibt es
einfach offene fragen ich für jede
kommune ist glaube ich diese
entscheidung wahnsinnig schwer zu
treffen wollen wir wirklich eine
versammlung untersagen obwohl da eben
versammlungsrecht betroffen ist und so
weiter aber die frage warum jemand
demonstrieren geht oder warum er
geschweige denn warum er nicht
demonstrieren gehen dürfte weil das
irgendwie einem ist ministerpräsidenten
nicht passt das kann nicht kann ich kaum
ernsthaft glauben dass das jemand laut
sagt und das in einem so hervorgehobenen
amt also das ist eine verkennung von
grundrechten da ist man schon mal kurz
sprachlos muss man einfach mal sagen ja
und in dieser sprachlosigkeit wollen wir
jetzt nur kurz verharren das vielleicht
mal
sacken lassen und bin auch gespannt ob
es darauf reaktionen gab ich wollte dass
hier nun mal so dass zum besten geben um
zu sehen in welcher in welchem punkt der
diskussion wie hier gerade sind aber
dann kommen wir jetzt noch schnell zum
bundesverfassungsgericht eine große
entscheidung die zwischen den jahren
ergangen ist auch dafür sehr für
aufmerksamkeit sorgte und die sich
darauf richtete dass es eigentlich keine
regeln der triage gibt
hier was war da los genau also triage
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zur
erklärung ist die ist die medizinische
entscheidung die ärztinnen und ärzte
treffen müssen wenn sie nur knappe
behandlungs ressourcen haben also wenn
es zum beispiel zu viele unfallopfer
gibt bei einem nehmen wir busunfall oder
so und es gibt einfach nicht genug
ressourcen um die zu behandeln nicht
genug tragen was auch immer in der coop
19 pandemie ist es natürlich vor allem
das problem von beatmungsgeräten
also es geht ja gar nicht nur immer
darum stehen genug betten zur verfügung
sondern stehen auch genug
beatmungsgeräte zur verfügung und da hat
eine gruppe behinderter menschen bis
nach karlsruhe geklagt also nahm eine
verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben und haben
gesagt wir fühlen uns
benachteiligt also artikel 3 absatz 3
satz 2 grundgesetz und artikel 25 der un
behindertenkonvention für die uranerz
ist ja immer mein job war nicht geregelt
ist wie mit behinderten menschen in so
einer situation umzugehen ist denn wir
gehen davon aus das ist ein risiko gibt
dass wir gedacht nicht werden und so
sieht das auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht dass sich dabei
dass dabei ich sage es mal so sogar sehr
betont dass sich auch sachkundige
einschätzung zu stützen und das argument
ist so ein bisschen das auch
sachverständige davon ausgehen dass
selbst ärztinnen und ärzte in seiner
komplexen entscheidung über eine
therapie das ist ja immer dann wirklich
das ist ja nicht die zeit die haben
subjektiv diskriminieren könnten also
dass selbst ärztin und ärzte
menschen mit behinderungen quasi oft
sachlich falsch beurteilen und unbewusst
in so einer art der typisierung also
dass man davon ausgeht dass zum beispiel
der behinderung
das risiko mit sich bringt kürzer zu
leben also ja mal brutal runtergebrochen
oder dass man zum beispiel bei
gebrechlichen menschen unbewusst davon
ausgeht dass die erfolgsaussichten bei
der behandlung weniger gut sind die
erfolgsaussichten bei der behandlung
sind als schon einen nach derzeit noch
geltendem recht ein zulässiges kriterium
also da gibt es quasi ärztliche
richtlinien hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber gesagt das
geht nicht die reichen auf gar keinen
fall aus die könnte es möglicherweise
sogar noch schlimmer machen und hat
gesagt wir brauchen dafür ein gesetz
also das muss der bundesgesetzgeber
regeln und er muss sicherstellen dass
allein nach der aktuellen und
kurzfristigen
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit entschieden
wird wenn es eben um die
mangelnde ressourcen bei
intensivpatienten geht und die
bundesverfassungsrichter sagen sehr
deutlich dass sie ist sehr wohl für
möglich halten also verfassungsrechtlich
möglich kriterien festzulegen nach denen
zu entscheiden ist wie knappe ressourcen
zur lebensrettung verteilt werden das
ist ja nun mal durchaus sehr sehr
verfassungsrechtlich komplex aber das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt sie halten
es für möglich so wird man
wahrscheinlich aber eher rechnen kann
und darauf weist auch karlsruhe hin es
würde auch zum beispiel ausreichen dass
man formale anforderungen dass man
schreibt also zum beispiel mehr augen
prinzip bei der entscheidung oder eine
längere dokumentation dass da mehr leute
drauf schauen und so weiter und der
senat sagt auch sehr deutlich sehr viel
spielraum des gesetzgebers bei der
ausgestaltung dieses gesetzes aber man
müsse eben auch die realität des
klinikalltags beachten also die enorme
eile unter den ärzten und erzähl
entscheidung treffen müssen und die
letztverantwortung des ärztlichen
personals also in der tat in dieser haut
möchte man häufig nicht stecken
vielleicht noch einmal um das deutlich
zu sagen also du hast jetzt gesagt es
gibt kriterien die festgelegt werden
müssen nach denen entschieden werden
muss und zwar geht da die nur die
kurzfristige
überlebensmöglichkeit also in dem
konkreten fall in der akuten erkrankung
situation nicht die längerfristige also
das heißt das alter kann eigentlich auch
keine rolle spielen
ja die ich fürchte dass die die frage so
einfach sie klingt so schwierig zu
beantworten ist eigentlich sollte das
nicht so sein es gibt aber in der
strafrechts wissenschaft durchaus sehr
sehr viele wissenschaftler innen die das
begann also die sagen dass das ein
anderes alter durchaus ein kriterium
sein könne dazu hat sich jetzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht zumindest und
klärt mitteilung aber gar nicht geäußert
und ich würde mich da jetzt ungern
festlegen wollte weil das hat mega
komplex und was ist mit dem status kann
nach dem differenziert werden
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass das
verfassungsgericht sichtbar wird auch
nicht beschäftigt hat würde aber relativ
klar nein sagen status heute ob ich das
gut finden es vielleicht eine andere
frage aber ich würde sagen
verfassungsrechtlich ein klares nein und
dazu findet sich natürlich nicht zu
entscheiden
so also der korona block liegt hinter
uns und jetzt
kümmern wir uns um einen veritablen
justizskandal fragezeichen liebe per du
sagst uns noch mal wer der afg politiker
jens meier eigentlich ist und warum er
uns überhaupt beschäftigen muss also
jens maier beschäftigt recht
journalistinnen und journalisten schon
länger in den vergangenen vier jahren
hat er auch die allgemeine politik
beschäftigt denn jens meier ist einer
der ich nochmal rechten oder rechts
radikalsten afg abgeordneten im
bundestag gewesen während mayer war von
2 17 bis zu 21 mit die des deutschen
bundestags und um ein bisschen einordnen
zu können sollte man wissen dass er sich
selbst einmal als kleinen hexe
bezeichnet hat also in anlehnung an die
anhörung der eben den völkischen flügel
der afg quasi geleitet hat der vom
verfassungsschutz bekanntlich jetzt
rechtsextremistische bestrebungen
eingestuft wird und der sich angeblich
mittlerweile aufgelöst hat also unser
herr jens meyer warten war dort sogar ob
man dieses völkischen flügels und im
sächsischen verfassungsschutzbericht
wird meyer namentlich als
rechtsextremist bezeichnet und um sich
ein bisschen ein bild machen zu können
muss man sagen dass die ehemalige ard
vorsitzende frauke petry ihn als zu
radikal aus der partei ausschließen
wollte damit sie aber damals damit nicht
durchgekommen und man kann sich
vielleicht dann ein wenig vorstellen wie
man da vor sich hat das ist alles
irgendwie schon unerfreulich genug aber
richtig übel wird es wenn man jetzt weiß
dass dieser mann in seinen
ursprünglichen job zurück möchte nachdem
er jetzt kein neues bundestagsmandat
bekommen hat jens meier ist nämlich
richter und sein richter amt hat gut
während er im bundestag war und jetzt
hat er am 23 dezember einen antrag auf
wiedereinstellung in den sächsischen
justiz dienst gestellt und ganz normaler
weise hätte man da auch gar nichts ging
ganz im gegenteil das ist bei
abgeordneten sogar explizit geregelt
dass sie wenn die in vorhelm im
beamtenverhältnis waren auch da wieder
zurückkehren genau das steht sogar im
gesetz man hat wenn man wenn man da war
dann ruht das dienstverhältnis quasi
solange man zb in die politik geht und
europaabgeordneter wird und dann hat man
rückkehr anspruch das steht im gesetz
also das bezweifelt auch keiner die
sächsische justiz machte sich jetzt
allerdings sehr sehr einfach indem sie
sich darauf zurück zieht und sagt na ja
der hat eine rückkehr anspruch wir
schauen jetzt mal was wir mit dem mann
machen dazu muss man wissen dass der
herr meier der war früher richter am
landgericht in dresden
schon während seiner zeit als richter
natürlich mehrfach auffällig geworden
ist weshalb ich eben auch sagen dass wir
recht journalistinnen gut oder eben
schlecht bekannt ist also 216 war glaube
ich das erste mal ist er so ein bisschen
auffiel da hat er als richter einem
recht renommierten politologen auf
antrag der achtung npd kritische
aussagen über die npd verboten das war
natürlich damals relativ brisant weil
dieser politologe gutachter beim npd
verbotsverfahren vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht und er konnte
sich damit nicht mehr uneingeschränkt
äußern nachher wurde der beschluss von
jens maier kassiert und die klage der
npd im hauptsacheverfahren abgewiesen
das hat aber damals schon für relativ
großen eklat gesorgt so 17 dann hat
meyer im öffentlich verständnis geäußert
für den rechts terroristen und
verurteilten mörder an dass bei weg und
hat eine skandal rede gehalten die ihm
einen verweis eingebracht hat in seinem
richter verhältnis damals hat ist er mit
partei rechtsaußen diana aufgetreten hat
sich gegen schwenker ausgesprochen und
den schuldkult der deutschen für
endgültig beendet erklärt und außerdem
hat er damals auch gesagt die npd sei
die einzige partei die immer geschlossen
zu deutschland gestanden habe also das
hat dann auch in der sächsischen justiz
durchaus für aufruhr gesorgt und hat ihm
ein disziplinarverfahren eingebracht er
hat damals ein verweis bekommen wegen
verstoßes gegen das richterliche mäßigen
ausgebuht dieses gebot besagt im
wesentlichen das richterinnen und
richter sich innerhalb und außerhalb
ihres amtes so verhalten müssen dass
keine zweifel an ihrer unabhängigkeit
aufkommen
abgesehen von dem verweis ist damals
nicht viel passiert meier musste seine
zuständigkeit abgeben für die meisten
medien und presse rechtssachen am
landgericht dresden das natürlich auch
wirklich absurd dass der ausgerechnet
dort saß denn da sind ja gerade in
dieser kammer sind natürlich relativ oft
parteien an dem verfahren beteiligt und
da hat es natürlich schon damals
befangenheitsanträge vielleicht nicht
geregnet aber die wurden sehr stark
befürchtet da hat das lg dresden dann
gesagt okay wir setzen den ma lin andere
kramer
das war so während seiner zeit als
richter schon also bevor er in den
bundestag gegangen ist zuhause beziehen
auch da hat er sich dann immer als sehr
krasser also selbst für afg verhältnisse
krasser abgeordneter generiert und 219
gab es noch einen öffentlichen vorfall
der wurde von seinem twitter-account aus
ich sage das mit voller absicht so ein
rassistischer tweet abgesetzt hat er
damals noah becker den sohn von boris
becker dem tennisspieler beleidigt er
hat behauptet den tweet habe er nicht
selbst verfasst das sei vermutlich ein
mitarbeiter gewesen er hat allerdings
nach einem vergleich ich glaube damals
in der zweiten instanz hat man sich
verglichen und er hat damals 7500 euro
an den noah becker
gezahlt jetzt hat er
ja und ja würde gern dahin zurück wo es
für ihn wieder sicheres geld gibt es hat
wohl gespräche beginnen gegeben ob er
die sächsische fdp landtagsfraktion
rechtlich beraten könnte die scheinen
gescheitert zu sein und jetzt muss die
sächsische justiz binnen drei monaten
also quasi bis knapp ende februar
es kann ab ende märz über den antrag
entscheiden ob er wieder in die justiz
darf du hast du schon gesagt kommen
normalerweise ist es lockt ein ding da
hat man einen rückkehr anspruch und
jetzt macht sich das ministerium schon
so ein bisschen einen schlanken fuß und
sagt er hat eben rückkehr anspruch und
verweist auch darauf dass der verweis in
seiner akte denen es eben gegeben hat
damals wegen dieser skandal rede mit
bioenergie ja mittlerweile auch verjährt
also dass verjährt bin zwei jahren und
deswegen sagen wir haben euch nix der
hat eine saubere acta der kann
zurückkommen so findest du das stimmt
oder herren die ihn irgendwie will noch
den die in gang setzen könnten um das zu
verhindern also
ich bin jetzt keine expertin für
richterliches dienstrecht und natürlich
ist es auch total richtig dass es im
grundsatz wahnsinnig schwierig ist
richter aus politischen gründen sage ich
jetzt mal los zu werden denn deshalb
sind richter ja gerade unabhängig und
deshalb lebt mit einem rechtsstaat damit
richter unabhängig sind und damit es
keinen politischen einfluss auf sie gibt
richter dürfen sich deshalb auch
politisch betätigen und auch irgendwie
ich sage mal deutlich politisch
betätigen aber meines erachtens geht es
hier schon nicht nur in
anführungszeichen um das richterliche
mäßigung gebot sondern richterinnen und
richter müssen ja nun mal auch garanten
dafür sein dass sie es steht sogar
richter gesetz jederzeit für die
freiheitliche demokratische grundordnung
im sinne des grundgesetzes eintreten und
für mich spricht eigentlich sehr viel
dafür dass jens meyer das nicht tut und
ich denke schon rechtsstaat muss
natürlich auch bereit sein und in der
lage sein verfassungsfeinde in den
eigenen reihen auszusortieren damit tut
sich die justiz schwer das wissen wir
schon seit jahren das ist auch nicht nur
in sachsen so aber in sachsen fällt es
halt schon häufiger auf also ich glaube
es ist erst zwei oder drei wochen her
dass ich in der folge mit helene das war
die folge 190 sehe ich hier gerade vom
15 12 über diesen rechtsradikalen
gesprochen habe diesen anhänger der
schlitzer partei der dritte weg der
jetzt in sachsen referendar werden darf
nachdem er in zwei anderen bundesländern
und bestätigt vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dort abgelehnt
wurde es gibt aber schon mittel und wege
also normalerweise gibt es natürlich das
disziplinarverfahren dass man schon
anwenden kann im richterlichen dienst
und zum beispiel gab es ja auch den
anderen afg abgeordneten thomas seit der
wahl von staatsanwalt und dem also der
ist aus dem amt befördert worden weil
ich glaube dass dienst gericht in
zweiter instanz gesagt hat okay
rassistisches gedankengut verbreitet und
die haben gesagt das reicht jetzt der
darf nicht mehr staatsanwalt sein weil
er sich nicht mehr auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes bewegt und das wiederum
könnte man machen wenn er dann wieder
als richter arbeitet aber bisher ging es
eben nicht weil er vier jahre lang
abgeordneter war und dann natürlich auch
die freiheiten eines abgeordneten also
buchstäblich genossen hat genau das
scheint tatsächlich erinnert hat das
problem zu sein die alten sachen sind ja
quasi verjährten er seine akte ist
sauber und das problem konnte hat jetzt
sein dass man einfach keine aktuellen
dienstvergehen hat also wenn man ihn
loswerden möchte sag ich jetzt mal so
der war eben nicht im richter dienst und
dann ist eben die frage gibt es
sozusagen pflichten die er aus dem
richter dienst mitgenommen hätte in den
dienst als abgeordneter da gibt es einen
sehr interessanten aufsatz im
verfassungs blog von professor andreas
fischer lescano das aufrechter aus
bremen der da durchaus einen sehr
deutlichen meinungsbeitrag geschrieben
hat im verfassungs blog schreiben wir
euch gerne in die chance da hat uns auch
eine höhere sind twitter darauf
aufmerksam gemacht sehr nett danke dafür
und
andreas fischer lescano führt einige
urteile des bundesverwaltungsgerichts
dafür auf dass es auch so eine art
nachwirkung der dienstpflichten gebe die
also jens maier auch als
bundestagsabgeordneter hätte beachten
müssen also das scheint jetzt aber nicht
unbedingt herrschende meinung zu sagen
ich glaube auch gar nicht dass das
unbedingt geklärt ist
fischer lescano verweist darauf dass man
halt so eine art endgültigen
vertrauensverlust annehmen könnte also
wenn man einfach davon ausgehen muss
dass der richter auch künftig seinen
dienstpflichten nicht ordnungsgemäß
nachkommen wird meine persönliche
meinung ist ja das sollte man zumindest
versuchen wenn ich in der sächsischen
justiz wäre würde ich das versuchen es
ist auch sehr interessant es gibt eine
ein anklageverfahren für richter die
sogenannte richter anklage in sachsen
steht das sogar in der landesverfassung
da kann auf antrag des landtags das
bundesverfassungsgericht anordnen dass
ein richter zu entlassen ist
das ist aber ich habe keine ahnung ob
das schon jemals genutzt wurde oder sona
ich habe wirklich habe ich vorher noch
nie gehört das habe ich jetzt in dem
kontext gelesen ob das schon mal
irgendwie angewendet wurde oder ob da
irgendwie darüber nachdenkt kann ich
nichts zu sagen aber ich finde es schon
es ist alles schwierig und natürlich
sollte es auch schwierig sein richter
aus dem dienst zu entfernen aber jens
meier ist halt meines erachtens nicht
einfach irgendwie politisch unliebsamer
richter oder so sondern der wird vom
sächsischen verfassungsschutz als als
rechtsextremist eingestuft er hat sich
glaube ich so weit außerhalb dessen
gestellt was ich als freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung ansehen würde
und das sah die sächsische justiz sich
jetzt so einen schlanken fuß macht und
den und einfach versucht den bei vollen
dienst beziehung das muss man ja auch
mal sagen irgendwo unterzubringen wo er
wenig schaden anrichten kann das finde
ich schon ehrlich gesagt kann alles
zumal das sächsische justizministerium
mittlerweile unter grüner leitung steht
und da könnte man finde ich durchaus
zumindest mal versuchen alles zu sagen
ja der hat halt eine rückkehr anspruch
und wenn der vorgesetzte denkt dass das
nötig ist dann können wir jetzt nach
seiner rückkehr gucken ob es ein
disziplinarverfahren gibt das ist echt
nicht viel da wird man gespannt sein
welche positionen ihm am ende
tatsächlich zugewiesen wird und wie
diese dann ausfüllt ja und ob er uns von
der presse da auch in zukunft noch
weiter beschäftigen oder ob der
öffentliche druck so groß wird dass die
sächsische justiz sich vielleicht doch
bewegt nur weil durchaus ich habe schon
das gefühl dass der öffentliche druck
steigt also dass da schon nicht sehr
viel empörung jetzt mittlerweile
entsteht aber dann wird es uns definitiv
noch weiter beschäftigen wir das wird er
nicht auf sich sitzen lassen wie kann
man schon mal mit sicherheit nicht wir
halten euch auf dem laufenden
wir kommen zu einem ganz anderen thema
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat seinen
instagram account wieder abgeschaltet
koma was da los ist
eine gute frage was ist denn los wir
haben uns entschieden das aufzugreifen
weil du ja auch sehr zu recht vor
einigen wochen sehr lobend erwähnt hast
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht diese
überhaupt hat ja dann mal in einer folge
darauf aufmerksam geworden und jetzt
wurde der abgeschaltet es war eine sehr
dürftige
dürftige begründung warum das so ist das
war eben ein projekt das zu zum
jahrestag also 70 jahre zum jubiläum des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes eingeführt
wurde und offensichtlich es entweder die
hat die arbeit überhand genommen oder
man war nicht so begeistert von den
reaktionen die man bekommen hat also
eher man weiß es letztendlich nicht es
wurde bis auf die tatsache dass es eben
ein befristetes projekt war zum 70
jubiläum des bundesverfassungsgesetzes
im nachhinein dass das ein befristetes
projekt sei das ist glaube ich eben beim
start damals nicht es wurde eben jetzt
als als begründung herangezogen aber
würdest du das in zweifel ziehen ich
könnte es mir tatsächlich vorstellen
also jedenfalls wurde es damals so nicht
kommuniziert und es kann natürlich sein
dass das intern so geplant war dass man
gesagt hat wir machen jetzt mal ins
account weil wir jetzt irgend ein paar
hübsche bildchen haben und vielen
feierlichkeiten vor der tür stehen und
so allerdings ist dass er normalerweise
eher ungewöhnlich dass man social media
kanal ich sage mal projektbezogen
eröffnet und dann wieder abschaltet also
und zumindest position nicht
kommuniziert damals ja und die frage ist
sozusagen ich meine ja was sind dann die
eigentlichen beweggründe die können wir
hier nicht liefern also wir finde es
bedauerlich aber dann wiederum hat mein
leben auch nicht verändert also können
wir uns auch nicht aber wir wollten sich
nicht vor
absolut
dann kommen wir jetzt noch zu einem
ernsteren thema in unseren updates
nehme ich das gesetz zur herstellung
materieller gerechtigkeit ist ein großes
wort ja dahinter steckt ein sehr
umstrittenes gesetz wir haben schon in
extension in folge
171 besprochen damals noch mit dem
geschätzten kollegen constantin von
linken erfolgreiches aufweichung des
doppelbestrafungsverbot
fragezeichen ja und damit ist auch schon
vieles hinlänglich gesagt wir wollen es
deswegen nur kurz halten die neuigkeit
ist jetzt dass es tatsächlich in kraft
getreten ist also der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hatte es hatte bedenken dagegen wie so
viele bedenken dagegen hatten und hat es
trotzdem ausgefertigt ist jetzt seit ein
paar tagen im jahr in kraft so zu sagen
aber es ist so umstritten dass
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann
schon mitgeteilt hat dass sie sich das
ganze noch mal ansehen möchte und da
womöglich zu einer weiteren reform kommt
ich weiß nicht genau wie diese reform
aussehen soll außer diesen die die
erweiterung reform rückgängig zu machen
streichen möchte um das noch mal
deutlich zu machen wie sagt man es gar
nicht so weit aus velsen aber es geht im
wesentlichen darum dass man das künftig
die justiz ist einfacher haben sollen
wirklich schweren fällen von mord
ein verfahren wieder aufzurollen wenn
neue erkenntnisse den sachverhalt
vielleicht in einem anderen licht
dastehen lassen so und wie gesagt da
haben wir den 103 eigentlich den das
verbot der doppelbestrafung und viele
kritiker sehen darin ein problem jetzt
werden wir sehen was die neue regierung
daraus macht und kommen zu einem anderen
äußerst wichtigen thema nein ist
natürlich nicht im ansatz so wichtig
aber wir haben darüber berichtet
deswegen möchten wir euch auch das
update geben der ehemalige trainer von
werder bremen markus anfang hat
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft in
bremen eingeräumt einen gefälschten
impfpass genutzt zu haben wir erinnern
uns der war am 20 11 ganz kurz vorm
spiel gegen schalke zurückgetreten
nachdem klar bekannt geworden war dass
die staatsanwaltschaft gegen ihn
ermittelte wegen nutzung eines
gefälschten passes und jetzt hat er das
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft
bestätigt zu geben man kann vermuten
dass er damit eine öffentliche
hauptverhandlung verhindern möchte also
da und 14 strafen viel zu erfahren geben
das ist ja nicht weiter ungewöhnlich in
fällen schwerer kriminalität kann man da
halt eine geldstrafe aussprechen und
dann gibt es keine öffentliche
hauptverhandlung und damit eben auch
keine öffentlichkeit das ist
wahrscheinlich jemandem der da
einigermaßen in der öffentlichkeit
gestanden hat ganz recht eine andere
frage ist
was bedeutet das eigentlich für seine
weitere sportliche karriere und da
möchte noch hinweisen auf einen sehr
schönen artikel des kollegen markus jung
von der faz der mit dem sportrechtler
paul lambert gesprochen hat aus
düsseldorf lasst das zum beispiel
bedeuten kann für die trainerlizenz und
so weiter für markus anfang den artikel
von markus jung packen wir euch in die
chance
sehr schön
und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon bei
unseren zwei gerechten urteilen die wir
haben das erste schätzt du vor das
eigentlich gar kein urteil also wir
haben ja diese kategorie immer sehr weit
gefasst es ist kann auch eine sehr
gerechte entscheidung denn das leben
vielleicht denken gerechte dinge und
manchmal auch ungerechte dinge deswegen
lassen wir das vielleicht einfach bei
gerechte urteile also ich finde es sehr
schön ich habe ein gesetz aus spanien
das ist schnell gesagt in spanien gibt
es jetzt ein neues gesetz zum geteilten
sorgerecht nämlich es gibt ein geteiltes
sorgerecht für haustiere
endlich das wechseln oder er gibt es
jetzt in spanien für tiere also der
richter muss ich jetzt bei einer
entscheidung darüber die richterin auch
muss sich bei einer scheidung darüber
gedanken machen wie er nach der trennung
hund katze maus oder vogel betreut und
die neat jährige fall soll jetzt eben
das wechselmodell werden das heißt die
tiere werden sind dann einmal bei der
frau und einmal bei man in aller regel
quasi abwechselnd weil die fischer
nämlich jetzt lebewesen mit eigener
sensibilität sind und nicht länger als
sachen gelten ich als hundebesitzerin
bin natürlich begeistert er entschuldige
bitte hier ich muss da kurz an geräten
weil du musst mir ein bisschen zu binär
unterwegs also es muss nicht immer in
uns ist nicht auf
heterosexuelle paare beschränkt diese
absolut natürlich nicht also natürlich
geht es für alle ihn also natürlich auch
wenn sich zwei männer oder wer auch
immer trend es geht um die tiere und es
geht darum dass dann das wechselmodell
der regelfall sein wird und der hund
dann einmal dort aus und einmal dort
sehr schön also das finden wir zutiefst
gerecht fragen uns natürlich auch wenn
das in deutschland hier mal verankert
wird bundesjustizminister marco
buschmann hat sich noch nicht dazu
geäußert
sehr schade so und jetzt du hast auch
noch ein gerechtes urteil für uns das
auf höherer post basiert genau gericht
das urteil dass uns unser hörer ansgar
dittmar
geschickt hat herzlichen dank dafür fand
ich wirklich auch sehr hell und passt
sehr gut in unsere serie unglaubliche
fälle mitten aus dem leben also man
glaubt er doch irgendwie gar nicht was
dann tatsächlich noch in unserer
aufgeklärten und modernen welt alles
möglich ist es geht nämlich um die
diskriminierung einer trans person
seitens eines potenziellen arbeitgebers
um das mal so diesen den schon das thema
zu benennen und das waren ganz bizarre
sachverhalt und ist eben auch vor dem
hintergrund dass diskriminierungs rechts
ganz interessant ich erzähl mal ein
bisschen worum es geht also da gab es
eine person
im ausweis stand eben das weibliche
geschlecht also offensichtlich diese
person ist mal als frau zur welt
gekommen und er hat aber inzwischen die
geschlechtsidentität als man angenommen
und hat das auch formell so erklärt im
ergänzungs ausweis der deutschen
gesellschaft trans identität und
intersexualität war das auch
festgehalten und der mann hatte eben
natürlich noch offiziell einen
frauennamen dass da war wohl der ausweis
noch nicht geändert und das quasi
behördliche verfahren noch nicht
eingeleitet aber der mann hat sich quasi
als man im bewerbungsgespräch auch
vorgestellt hat auf diese
also auch ganz offen damit umgegangen
hat das im bewerbungsgespräch auch offen
thematisiert und war auch wohl kein
problem und danach gab es noch den einen
oder anderen austausch also mann war
eben zum ergebnis gekommen dass dieser
mann tatsächlich ein
ausbildungsverhältnis da eintreten kann
also dass er ausgebildet werden kann zu
einer sicherheits zum
sicherheitspersonal
so und dann dauerte das alles ein
bisschen und bis dann der
anstellungsvertrag kam und es ging hin
und her aber grundsätzlich hat der
arbeitgeber auch immer deutlich gemacht
ja wir sind interessiert also sie
kriegen bei uns eine anstellung und
das zog sich in weichen und
irgendwann kam dann aber zu der
überraschung dass des mannes die
erklärung also passen sie mal auf wir
haben uns das doch anders aus überlegt
also konkret wo das gesagt wir müssen
ihnen leider mitteilen dass wir von der
zusage des ausbildungsvertrages
zurücktreten müssen also so weit war man
schon gekommen aber die begründung war
wirklich ziemlich bizarr denn da stand
nämlich drin bitte klären sie die
formalitäten und wenn sich gern noch mal
an uns mit übereinstimmung der papiere
zu ihnen und ihrer persönlichkeit werden
wir zu einem späteren zeitpunkt in ein
ausbildungsverhältnis treten ja also wir
sagen man sich jetzt auch echt nicht
wundern wenn man verklagt
also entscheiden sich jetzt mal ob mann
oder frau sein sollen und claire sind es
und bevor das nicht geklärt ist können
wir sicher auch nicht anstellen was eine
ziemlich bizarre erklärung es jedenfalls
panthers gericht das so und dem können
wir uns natürlich anschließenden wir
finden zutiefst gerechtes urteil aber
ich mache noch mal die herleitung weil
wie gesagt dass es juristisch auch
relativ interessant also geht natürlich
um ein
entschädigungsanspruch nach dem
allgemeinen gleichbehandlungsgesetz wer
geht es konkret um
paragraf 15 ja und da kann man
entschädigung verlangt in solchem fall
maximal drei gehälter die man eben
verdient hätte wenn man da wie
versprochen dieses anstellungsverhältnis
eingehen hätte eingehen können so in
diesem fall waren roundabout 2000 euro
dazu muss man wissen der arbeitgeber
hatte schon ein bischen was vorgestreckt
hatte schon eingesehen dass das nicht so
super gelaufen ist und als
auszubildender hätte der 850 euro dafür
dient so
und dann hatte das gericht das eben
ordentlich durch geprüft und hat gesagt
na ja wir haben hier ja offensichtlich
mit einer benachteiligung wegen dass der
sexuellen orientierung zu tun und in
solchen fall also wenn die diensten auf
eine solche benachteiligung hindeuten
bzw sie vermuten lassen dann gibt es
eine beweislastumkehr das heißt der
arbeitgeber muss zeigen dass er kein
verstoß begangen hat also dass er dient
das ein wichtiges gemeldet hatte
diskriminiert hat so und hier hat dann
das gericht sorgfältig durch geprüft und
natürlich hat der arbeitgeber auch
diverse dinge dann zur rechtfertigung
der preis gegeben hat ihnen gesagt na ja
wir haben ihm ihr angeboten ja dass wir
die ausbildung machen nachdem er die
verhältnisse geklärt hat das hat das
gericht nicht ganz
verstanden warum das überhaupt nötig sei
denn der arbeitgeber hat deutlich
gemacht einen ausbildungsvertrag darf
nur mit dem namen geschlossen werden der
im tatsächlich im pass steht und der
mann hat eben darauf bestanden dass ein
neuer name da genutzt wird und auch da
hat offensichtlich gericht der
schützenhilfe geleistet gesagt also das
überzeugt uns nicht warum jetzt
ausgerechnet dieser grund dagegen stehen
sollte
und auch das pauschale argument das fand
ich auch ganz interessant dass der
arbeitgeber und dass er auch noch ein
sich diese arbeitgeber hat sich dann
sehr offen gezeigt und sehr
sehr unproblematisch und sehr auch schon
für auch transsexuelle
mitarbeitern und hat gesagt wir
beschäftigen ja schon ein paar und auch
das hat der das gericht bei seite
geschoben hat gesagt der arbeitgeber
erhalte hierdurch kein freifahrtschein
für diskriminierung an anderer stelle
ja also man das wäre ja auch noch
schöner das ist so das argument ich kann
doch niemanden rassistisch
diskriminierend wenn ich mit einer
ausländerin verheiratet bin ja da
sträuben sich ein ja die macken haben
ging auch also and all das hat das
gericht abgebügelt und dann den
arbeitgeber zu einem zu einer
entschädigung in höhe von 2000 euro
verdonnert so und ob es tatsächlich
irgendwann doch noch mal zu einem
ausbildungsverhältnis kommt weiß man
nicht ich wage es zu bezweifeln
da war habe ich nach dem klageverfahren
auch zu bezweifeln aber wer weiß das
schon wir fanden das urteil auf jeden
fall zutiefst gerecht und verabschieden
und damit für diese woche oder corinna
ja danke wirklich sehr herzlich für die
aufmerksamkeit und wie gesagt hoffen
noch sehr auf weiteres feedback das
hilft uns immer sehr wir kriegen
wirklich sehr sachliche hinweise bringt
uns immer weiter wenn wir von ihnen wenn
wir von euch hören also noch mal ein
spruch podcast faz.de oder auch auf
unserer internetseite oder auch auf den
pott klettern wo man hin und wieder auch
mal
insbesondere bei apple bewertungen
hinterlassen haft aber freuen wenn sich
auch natürlich nur über gute bewertung
so habt eine gute woche da draußen
[Musik]